for labor and delivery nurses at an  Atlanta Hospital came under Fire over a  tick tock video in which they shared the  things that annoyed them about expecting  mothers and their families well we've  already told you to push the call light  but every five minutes your family  member coming up the front desk  in a blanket another egg when you're  going room  your mama and your other baby mama oh  Nick see that it's the unlimited trips  to the nurse's station for me well  ladies the good news is that you don't  have to worry about any of those icks  anymore the bad news is that you're  going to discover a new ick which is  called unemployment